i can sit here [ __ ] you you're a piece
of [ __ ]
i don't like you that's just a tick i
promise
i figured you know
we have tourette syndrome get with a bit
all right it bothers me when people
laugh at my tics three
two one go
i have a lot of funny tics whether it's
just word ticks whether it's a big
movement whether it's
my cussing ticks uh i also make
uh social media content on tick tock
exploring
uh the funny sides of tourette's and
what it's like to live with tourette's
and
when i'm with my friends we laugh at my
tics because they're funny
cow and when people
laugh with me at my tics then i feel
more accepted and i feel more myself and
i feel like i can
freely tick but if you're laughing at me
that's a whole different story if you're
making fun of me
that's that's drawing the line i
realized that what would be way worse
than being laughed at is if like my
eric's friends and peers and family were
like
trying to baby me you know and like be
tiptoe around me and like
walking on thin ice like i would much
rather be
like made fun of from somebody that i
don't care about then like
know that i'm being treated differently
by the people in my life just because i
have
this thing sometimes i'll say something
like just kind of mean all around
really insulting to someone at that
point it's like the only way to play it
off is if it's like a friend of course
is to like laugh at it be like
wow that's such a ridiculous thing i
just said what so it definitely does
depend on the tick
anyone who like laughs at me like
they're my boys like like i just met
them like yeah like
laughing my twitches i don't care about
like i don't care if you don't laugh
you're gonna look at me weird
then i'm gonna be like yo what the [ __ ]
are you looking at bro like
the [ __ ] everybody here is laughing just
look at me that's like disrespectful
right there you know i think it
definitely is a distinction of laughing
at someone rather
than with them again using common sense
like summer [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you so cute [ __ ] you first
um i went to a restaurant like a couple
weeks ago
and wow i was ticking pretty bad wow
[ __ ] off
and the table across from me started
like laughing at me and trying to get me
to tick and
like wow just treating me like a
sideshow more than anything
and that was really not appreciated okay
so this is fun so there's hot takes that
our audience has submitted
which are assumptions that they make
about people with tourettes
i didn't know what they're about
having sex is hard because of my tics
it makes it better yeah i call it the
twitch stroke that's what it's calling
i'm saying oh god i'm heading with the
tip
and like i could go for like hours all
night six hours
it's like endurance yeah i twitch
sometimes here and there but it's like
they don't they don't care like they
like it it's weird it's okay for people
with
tourette's to say the n-word if it's a
tick
i i have that tick and um
you know it depends on the the context
of the situation you know if you're like
an actual really shitty person and you
enjoy saying it
and someone's like oh yeah like i really
want to say this word but
it's okay because i have tourette's
people just excuse it as a tourettes but
really no it's not okay but you know
with this certain tick i sometimes don't
know when it's coming and i have no
control over holding it back
it's not right for anyone to say that if
they
you know aren't black but the thing is
it's involuntary you can't control
having this disorder you can't control
what you say but i still agree that like
in normal conversation don't say it
unless you have the right to say it
would just say that i'm only over here
because it's the way the tourette's
works in my mind and probably a lot of
others
it's like what you want to do or say the
least
is the thing that your tourette's wants
you to do or say the most
verbal tics sometimes show your true
feelings
so i can sit here [ __ ] you you're a
piece of [ __ ]
i know i don't like you [ __ ] you that's
just a tick i promise
i figured you know i can go around
saying
i want a boyfriend but do i actually
want a boyfriend maybe not
um maybe i do i don't know it kind of
depends i have some vocal tics where i
call them my truth ticks
and i'll be like do you want to know a
secret about this person and then i'll
be like you
have hair or you're tall like
it's things like that so in the those
cases it's not really very healed
heal for tourettes like sometimes i will
say what i'm feeling but most of the
times it's just coming from somewhere in
my brain that i have jeans
no idea these are mom jeans the most
comfortable
dating is hard three
two one go
i don't think tourette's makes it harder
not at all like to be honest no i'm just
i think it's just hard in like this
generation nowadays
it's just hard dude you can't that's it
but threats never affected me with like
finding somebody you know i agree that
dating in general is hard
adding my personal tourettes on it makes
it a hundred times harder
every single second of every day i'm
ticking whether you notice it or not is
a different story like i've literally
gone on dates and just been so anxious
and been ticking so much that i just
i ended up leaving and like the other
person seems visibly uncomfortable so it
just takes
that much harder to find someone who's
willing to commit
those little things where like you know
i can't cuddle with someone because the
second they touch me i like tense up and
i like unless like you know
although i do want to cuddle with them
so yeah it really just depends on the
severity but for me it's it hasn't been
so bad but just because i don't believe
that it's hard doesn't mean that
her blaming his heart is invalid yeah
definitely with things like cuddling or
hand holding i feel very restricted and
my tics are like let's break out right
now
so that's a bit difficult but i think if
you find the right person that isn't
just with you to pity you because of
your condition then it's
wow a lot easier i feel um very lucky
i've been
with my boyfriend now for almost six
years when we
first got together we were friends for
quite a while beforehand and so he very
much knew
the severity of my tics and because he
saw my tics probably at their worst and
at their best
even when i was dating before we were
together i'm very
upfront about my ts from the get-go
because
i found that it's almost like a um i
don't know if the word is litmus test
but
my tics make it so that the people who
are around me are generally better
people
and um because they're people who are
more accepting and more understanding
but that's my issue is finding the right
person because i'm up front that i have
tourette's and i tell them like the
severity of it they see my tick tock
they see my instagram
and then i get ghosted and then i get
swiped left on or
they find someone else has anyone ever
lost a relationship
because of um tourette's it's just my
other you know
terrible personality traits not the
tourettes
i feel like anybody who is going to
break up with somebody because of their
ts
i think a lot of people don't want to
seem ableist so they're going to find
some other reason to tell you so for all
i know maybe i have been broken up with
because of my ts but
who knows like i have lost
opportunities because of my disability
three two one go
since you're the only one over there why
do you if you don't mind me asking why
do you
somewhat disagree i feel like i haven't
necessarily lost opportunities because
of my ts
i've had some cases where i don't go
after opportunities because
of it but i haven't necessarily had
somebody
tell me no just because of my ts it
would have been for other reasons
i had to drop out of school due to my
tourette's syndrome i was
asked to leave certain classes i was
asked to leave a starbucks once
at a tourette convention i was asked to
leave a place
and all of us had tourette's but i was
the only one with coprolalia or the only
one with cussing ticks
and then i also can't keep a job because
i
would get yelled at by the customers yes
the job was aware that i had tourette's
and aware that i couldn't control it
but then the customers would make a
scene and then therefore i couldn't work
therefore made my anxiety worse made my
trust worse and
ultimately ended up me having to go on
disability because i wasn't allowed to
work
in high school like ever since i started
playing sports i was really good but
the coaches drop out all the coaches
always just like hated on me like
always said something about me and
that's why i wouldn't play so i had to
transfer schools like three times
i was good at football and like i
couldn't play the first five games so
like you just like
like lessened my opportunities to get
offers you know it was a dream of mine
but like after that i was like [ __ ]
but like obviously like now i have great
opportunities coming my way because i
don't give a [ __ ]
i'm living my life so like you know i
regret nothing
that i did you know i haven't had like
many opportunities to lose but like it
definitely
impacts what i'm able to do like for
example i do like swim
in school and sometimes i have to like
stop and take a break because my tics
are so bad that i like
can't swim so like things like that will
happen where it definitely does
affect luckily i have not drowned yet
okay good
yeah yeah key keyword i used to work
retail before my tics got bad
and similar to you it manifested in me
cussing out a lot of customers
so i didn't keep that job for very long
afterwards and
that beans [ __ ] you um
after that a i have failed every single
interview that i've tried to go to
so i've kind of just given up on getting
rehired but
hopefully going back to online school
because i was also forced to drop out of
that
so i do like engineering and sound
stuff but that doesn't count [ __ ] you no
i can't i can't
i can work from home and i don't have a
lot of face to face
with clients when i'm when i'm on like a
zoom meeting or something for a project
i make sure to have the push to talk
so i don't scream why all these people
are doing things
i feel like i'm very good at suppressing
my tics which i know none of us like to
do
but every job that i've ever had has
been like a lot of like
backstage stuff so if my tics are too
bad and i can't suppress them
my employers have always been very good
about finding me something to do where
i'm not face to face
[Music]
i wish i was born without tourette's
three two one go
i mean i've had it start seven so like
[ __ ] it
it's been hard you know and i got brain
surgery for it finally i have like
like fifty percent better but i used to
be like non-stop just like body
movements like twitching when i walked
the only way it's done if i was high as
[ __ ] just smoking weed all day
and like after surgery i stopped
swimming for four months but
i would like wow why not like i'd like
to experience life without tourists
without having to be freaking
taking pills like twitching out
uncontrollably i've told this to people
and they don't
understand but like i don't know what it
feels like to relax i don't know what
it's like to
go to a movie at a theater and not be
just stressed and miserable and
barely able to pay attention the entire
time i've been asked that same question
my instant answer is always no no
hesitation
even though i go through all of that
turmoil and all that stress and all of
the
honesty trauma because of it it's made
me the person i am today
like i know way more about myself and my
mental health and
being socially aware of like the person
i am and i think
the pros definitely outweigh the cons
there's a lot of cons
physically for myself but i'd rather
for the sake of humanity in people and
advocacy in loving people
i'd much rather deal with this so that i
can be there for everybody else
i'm so so glad that i was introduced to
the tourettes community which by the way
are the
most amazing people you'll ever meet
every person with tourette's
and i'm not even joking when i say this
always has some unique
talent all of them are the nicest people
and they have a really good outlook on
life
i wouldn't trade the friends that i've
made in the community for anything i
feel like my
ts has given me so much more empathy
for people and i feel like it's such a
part of who i am
i'm very passionate about the talents
within the tourette community i
am actually for the past seven years
have been hosting an event called
artistic
expressions where i just showcase
talents of people with tourette syndrome
when we're doing something that we
really love to do
so for me it used to be when i was
reading books or when i was singing or
when i was dancing
i would stop ticking and i think that
might be why so many people have
such creative outlets is because that is
the only time sometimes where we can
just
feel still for me it's playing an
instrument most of the time it's guitar
and when i pick it up i don't tick it
all i actually got introduced to the
the tourette community by showing up at
rihanna's event and just finding out
that everybody was like the same
it's like oh yeah that person plays
drums this person reads poetry this
person does that and nobody's ticking
why they're doing it
it's almost like magic it is it's magic
it is magic
how was this experience for you guys
today amazing
good really fun life-changing that is
officially a wrap
and we brought you some jubilee merch
oh yay how exciting oh thank you so much
oh and i've been looking for new
stickers can i take a picture with all
of you actually yeah
yeah um i shake too much to take it so
do you think you can take it
[Music]
beans